hello and welcome to our podcast today
we will be discussing the Dunning Kruger
effect which is a cognitive bias that
affects people's perception of their own
abilities the effect was for described
by social psychologist David Dunning and
Justin Krueger in 1999 and it has since
become a popular Topic in Psychology and
Beyond the dunning-kruger effect is
named after David Dunning and Justin
Krueger a social psychologist who first
described the phenomenon in the 1999
study which was called unskilled and
unaware of it how difficulties in
recognizing one's own incompetence lead
to inflated self-assessment the term
dunning-kruger effect itself was coined
by journalist David mccraney in his book
you are not so smart which popularized
the concept to a wider audience
the term effect is used to describe the
observable phenomenon of people
overestimating their abilities despite
their lack of knowledge or expertise the
names of the researchers are used to
credit them for their contribution to
the development and understanding of
this cognitive bias however there have
been instances where public figures have
demonstrated overconfidence in their
abilities despite despite a lack of
expertise or knowledge in a particular
area which can be seen as an example of
the dunning-kruger effect here are a few
possible examples
in 2019 musician B.o.B made headlines
for his belief that the Earth is flat
despite overwhelming scientific evidence
to the contrary Bob persisted in his
belief and even launched a crowd funding
campaign to launch a satellite to prove
his theory
this could be seen as an example of the
dunning-kruger effect where Bob
overestimated his own knowledge and
expertise in science and astronomy in
2020 singer Madonna posted a video on
social media claiming that a vaccine for
covid-19 had already been developed but
was being suppressed by the
pharmaceutical industry this could be
seen as an example of the dunning-kruger
effect where Madonna overestimated her
own knowledge and understanding of
medicine and Public Health in 2008 a
reality TV star was criticized for
promoting a line of appetite suppressant
lollipops on social media many Health
experts and eating disorder Advocates
spoke out against the promotion arguing
that it could be harmful and misleading
to Young fans this could be seen as an
example of the dunning-kruger effect
where the famous girl overestimated her
own knowledge and influence in the field
of nutrition and health
what is actually the done in Kruger
effect and how is it seen or spotted
among famous people
the Dunning Kruger effect refers to the
phenomenon where people who lack
knowledge or expertise in a particular
area tend to overestimate their
abilities in that area essentially they
don't know that they don't know and as a
result they believe they are more
competent than they actually are
on the other hand people who do possess
expertise in a particular area tend to
underestimate their abilities because
they are aware of how much there is
still to learn this means that there is
often an inverse relationship between
confidence and competence those who are
most confident in their abilities may
actually be the least competent
there's another perspective of uh done
in Kruger effect that can be manifested
in real life
the Dunning Kruger effect can manifest
in various ways in everyday life for
example have you ever had a friend who
thinks they are an expert in something
but in reality they are just barely
scratching the surface of knowledge this
is a classic example of the
dunning-kruger effect
another example is when people think
they can do something without any
training or experience such as fixing
the car or performing a medical
procedure these individuals may not be
aware of the complexity of the task and
the amount of knowledge and skill
required to perform it competently and
there's this other question that most
people who have come across the done in
Kruger effect have asked this question
why is a Dunning Kruger effect so
important to understand
understanding this is essential for
several reasons firstly it helps us
recognize when we may be overconfident
in our abilities and need to seek out
more information or training to improve
this is particularly important in areas
such as medicine where overestimating
one's abilities can have serious
consequences
secondly it can help us be more
empathetic towards others who may be
struggling with a dunning-kruger effect
instead of dismissing them as arrogant
or ignorant we can understand that they
may genuinely believe that they are
competent in an area where they are not
lastly understanding the dunning-kruger
effect can help us become better
Learners by recognizing that there is
always more to learn and that we may not
have all the answers we can approach new
information with humility and an open
mind in order to understand the Dunning
Kruger effect we have gathered a few
real life examples
if a student who thinks they are a great
writer because they received a high
grade on their High School essays but
struggles to write a coherent college
level paper
another example of a Dunning Kruger
effect is a person who thinks they can
diagnose their own illness
and chooses not to seek medical advice
from a trained professional leading to a
delay in treatment and potentially
worsening their condition
another example of it of the
dunning-kruger effect might be a manager
who believes they are excellent at
leading their team but fails to
recognize their team's dissatisfaction
and high turnover rate another example
might be a novice cook who thinks they
can make a complicated dish without
following the recipe or understanding
the cooking techniques resulting in a
disappointing outcome and another
example of the tunnel Kruger effect
might be a person who thinks they are
great driver despite having multiple
accidents and receiving tickets for
traffic violations this effect is not
limited to humans Studies have shown
that other animals such as rats can also
demonstrate the phenomenon and when
study rats were trained to perform a
task and were then divided into two
groups one group was allowed to watch a
video of itself performing the task
while the other group was not the group
that watched the video showed a creator
of overconfidence in their abilities
compared to the group that didn't the
Dunning Kruger effect can be influenced
by culture and upbringing Studies have
shown that people from individualistic
cultures such as the United States are
more likely to overestimate their
abilities compared to the people from
collectivist cultures such as Japan the
Dunning Kruger fact can also be
influenced by mood and emotions people
who are feeling happy or confident or
more likely to overestimate their
abilities while people who are feeling
anxious or uncertain are more likely to
underestimate their abilities this
effect has been used to explain various
real world phenomena such as the
overconfidence of the CEOs and the poor
performance of certain political leaders
this effect has also inspired various
internet memes and jokes such as the
popular phrase I know enough to be
dangerous it's worth noting that the
Myers-Briggs type indicator known as the
mbti is a popular personality assessment
tool that categorizes individuals into
one of the 16 personality types based on
four dichonomies
extraversion or introversion sensing and
intuition thinking or feeling and the
last one the last criteria is judging or
perceiving while there may be some
overlap between personality traits and
cognitive biases there is currently no
conclusive evidence linking the mbti
personality types with a done in Kruger
effect where is this Dunning where is
this effect is a cognitive bias that can
affect people across old personality
types and is more closely related to a
lack of knowledge or expertise in a
particular area rather than the
personality traits it's important to
approach both the mbti and the
dunning-kruger effect with a critical
and open-minded perspective and to
recognize that neither tool can fully
capture the complexity and uniqueness of
human personalities or cognitive biases
in a nutshell the dunning-kruger effect
is a well-established psychological
phenomenon that has been studied and
support by scientific research
and as we already said that it was first
described in 1999 a paper published by
psychologist David Dunning and Justin
Krueger that who conducted a series of
experiments to demonstrate the
aforementioned phenomenon their research
showed that people who lack knowledge or
expertise in a particular area are often
unable to accurately assess their own
abilities and may overestimate their
skills or knowledge this overconfidence
can lead to poor decision making as well
as a resistant to feedback or criticism
the Dunning Kruger effect is now
considered to be a well-established
cognitive bias and is taught in many
introductory psychology courses in
conclusion the dunning-kruger effect is
a fascinating cognitive bias that
affects how we perceive our own
abilities by understanding this
phenomenon we can become better Learners
more empathetic individuals and
ultimately more competent in the areas
we care about thank you for listening to
our podcast I guess I'll see you next
time have a great one